hello good to see you how are you it's
you oh there's one thing I gotta ask you
about sir you are slaying the red carpet
thank you thank you but he couldn't stop
talking about your custom louis vuitton
harness what made you want to wear that
babe harness harness bad boy no I well
just now that was actually that was
meant to be worn under a chute and then
we tried it with the jacket on the day
and FaceTime Virgil who made the suit
and he said no go without it that's like
go without the jacket that's the that's
the way to you know that that it's
presenting itself so that's all that's
all it was but it's just a fun way you
know it's a form of expression it's a
form of artistic expression in a way and
how'd you pick this suit tonight
um I should like honestly like on
Instagram like scrolling around and and
I'm a big Alexander McQueen fan and
that's when I used to go in y-you I did
a fashion class there we watched a
documentary on his work and I believe
the reaction that the the bib did get
were you surprised because it was all
over I just didn't know some of this
stuff like I said I went on Ellen this
week I didn't know there was like sex
dungeon culture like things like that
associated with it but definitely
surprising but again it's just I think
it's just a form of expression in a way
yeah and and yeah
you